good morning everyone how's it going
thank you for tuning in I'm Ritchie and
I'm here with David today we are gonna
continue our gameplay of Tim Tim we're
gonna try to evolve our starter Tim Tim
and kind of rush through the next few
dojos here right just like our day two
of the stream we started last time yeah
in the middle of a play if you want to
cut to the excellent the game let's go
um yeah exactly so there's like there's
a couple of dojos right in the Alpha
right now yes there's like four dojos so
good amount of content considering this
is just an alpha it's pretty extensive
yeah I haven't found like a hard end to
it yet right we're still going yeah
exactly we're still going and like even
now we played for about an hour and a
half on stream yesterday right then you
know I played for like two more hours
once I got off stream and we're still
like about to reach the first dojo
because there's like two three different
of cities and you just keep going it's
just like these like fetch quests you
keep finding more trainers and stuff
that's right they stacked a lot of
quests onto you little sites clients and
stuff like that talking to people you
meet exactly exactly you have the option
to like help random you know people
local towns folks things like that we
have our starter crystal as we saw Mike
out yesterday we had we're playing on
Ritchie soon he had a different starter
you paid that's right
oh I renamed it Alex I forgot it's real
name but it was like it was like the
psychic version right or mental typist
yeah that's what they call the mental in
the game it had some really cool moves
but you know it's nice to see you the
other starter here what was the name of
your sergeant Christal okay and
coincidentally it's also a crystal type
Pokemon so okay well this one
and then this little type is just like
crystal okay but the crystal type it's
green I mean I'm assuming it's like
grass is it the grass type uh so no
grass type is actually a nature okay
it's called nature in the game but this
is like that's cool your your Tim Tim
looks like a little chameleon yeah how
we doin chat you guys uh get four day to
alpha then we keep rolling and it's not
easy
no go ahead if you had a friendship
mechanic I have to get crystal to wall
30 levels while it's in my care Wow okay
and we're about halfway there so
hopefully we can we're on that grind now
in the next hour and a half
got to keep Krystal alive can I turn you
up a little bit integer sure sure so
we've got a couple of um oh there you go
here you've got a couple of questions in
chat that were pretty common yesterday
to where oh yeah I know like is the game
pc only and things like that you want to
yeah I'll take over for that yeah
absolutely right now it is in we have a
we got a code early but early access for
steam on PC is the 21st right so we did
get it early fortunately it's very cool
but it'll be this will be available for
everyone early access to the 21st and
then the the rest of the consoles it's
planned for Nintendo switch ps4 and Xbox
one down the line they're saying 20
maybe even 20 21 right it's all to be
announced all in the air right now but
it'll be coming to PC first
yeah that was a powerful move yeah
like took out my health and oh no poison
sorry I think like a lot of the symptoms
in the wild and from trainers they're
kind of a cakewalk so it's nice to start
pacing yeah I had some good luck early
on everything was you know low level
good enough I wasn't getting in like
bullied so much towards the like towards
the time I stopped playing yesterday I
played a little after stream also I got
my butt handed to me if you like by some
some trainers with like more than to
tempt em right they call them tamers
actually in this I keep saying trainer
but you know harder it's hard to undo
you know fill the consoles right now you
can only get this on we have a really
early code but early access for PC will
be available on the 21st
but it's planned for consoles no word as
to win though all of them though switch
ps4 Xbox one no mobile either right not
announced anyway
[Music]
you look so happy there it's so nice
that just cool right here
oh nice here right there Delisle says
looks like a straight Pokemon ripoff
could be fun that's kind of the
sentiment like it's so yeah I mean it
were we are having fun there's something
you know it's I kept saying yesterday
it's not a bad thing to be take so much
inspiration from a successful already
game we love and switch it up there are
MMO elements for sure I think that's
their big takeaway and there's always a
chat on the bottom left you can interact
with people who show up on your screen
live roads changes it up a little and
plus we were talking about the learning
curve yesterday with battle there are
smaller adjustments to the techniques of
the battle techniques you can do but
it's still comfortable enough like we
got into it after like an hour was just
fine
[Music]
till he'll Triple A developers shun the
switch now I don't know man
NT productions this was not on the
switch it's currently we have a we have
early code but it'll be on PC first in
early access on the 21st
consoles later on hey self gamer what's
going on welcome to the chat welcome to
the stream we are trying to level up our
tempt M it to evolve to a second form
takes longer than we thought but there
is a technique and we're gonna try to
just rush to do it today yeah be a ball
making on him yeah bombs are just like
potions they're not actual revised
revised okay I'll just level of
something else there you go
this is actually evolved already the
correct oh right from Pajaro yeah
exactly the payara it's cool that
control voice bow in the chat says these
temp temp designs are getting cool
that's what I was telling David like
they're the starter ones like there they
become you know just like Pokemon game
you see a lot in the beginning that are
common kind of small simple designs but
the further we're moving on into this
game the more unique designs we're
seeing right like I haven't seen that
one on the left that kind of is that
what yeah is that what crystal becomes
[Music]
okay no well it's good we didn't spoil
it I know I know what crystal looks like
okay cool out that although you can
apparently catch your starters out in
the wild like later on after like oh
cool there's or something I was reading
up on the wiki yesterday trying to kind
of get my you know bearings a little bit
more yeah this on this game and that
seems to be the case that's cool
I pushed us away off-screen so we can
see the battle but then all will be back
in the lab we want you guys to see the
in-game text although the bottom-right
looks pretty empty that's cool oh nice I
have that little sport
Tim Tim also that Kaku is that who that
is
the bottom right yeah I have that one
too it has that cool spore attack nice
it doesn't attack I like that one a lot
nice made some money and we're back and
heal up again yeah go for it it's good
that it's so close is it out now no
currently it's not we do have an early
alpha build here and you will be able to
play this alpha build on the 21st on
Steam only currently it's planned for
all consoles but no dates yet I'm not
sure it might be it might be a different
one yeah because there is some time for
them to patch things up maybe they'll
call it a beta after this point maybe
cuz this isn't really feeling alpha it's
going smooth overall the only problem I
think I've seen is what are the temp
temp those temp temp cards they used to
capture Tim Tim yeah there's a glitch
where at least I had experiences
yesterday where you throw one and
nothing happens it takes two like
they're just there was a menu glitch or
after I selected a temp temp card it
just acted like I didn't but it wasted
one so oh great double up on your cards
they're probably gonna patch that's yeah
that's a quick one to fix I assume so
there's this thing you'll notice how it
my green health bar is flashing chat
that's cuz like there's yeah it's
actually actually chat just mentioned so
Bao said has MP management gotten
annoying so far I don't think it's
gotten annoying it's only annoying
because I go into autopilot and remote
way too easily sure and and that can you
know kind of catch you off-guard
sometimes like you'll overexert your
time some things like that
yeah they knock themselves out from
being overworked right oh well you know
you're right you do that to them yeah
but you got to keep that in check that's
all I think it's kind of a cool thing
but it does bother me that I can't see
my experience bar until until like
they're after yeah because you know I
don't have a good short-term memory and
especially if I'm gonna be speedrunning
like I'm doing here for you guys I would
just like to see where my experience bar
is at all times right yeah that's just
something that that auto that autopilot
mode is a very real thing I don't have
this one I've wanted to catch this one
so I might do that I think it's a good
experience once even for caching which
is nice yeah that's go I didn't know
that I do like how I'm not sure in the
light and sorted shield or any later
iteration of Pokemon if they have this
but in the middle of a battle you can
you you earn your XP and they show you
in the middle of the battle and you can
also alert I learned a new move in the
middle of a battle yeah oh you can't
okay cool that's cool I like that it's a
welcome addition to this game too for
sure cuz I learned it and it helped me
like win the battle I got rid of like
heck and then it was like for a much
stronger move yeah crystal dust oh no oh
that's good you're wack
down to the red so I can just happen
this is cool though you're in the caves
now I didn't make it this far yesterday
it's nice to see a change of scenery
here yeah it really is
what's your pinging chat is asking what
is your opinion Pokemon like mm oh come
any point like this this game I assume
if you suck about this game yep we've
got some pretty interesting opinions
we're probably talking about more here
yeah stay tuned yeah if we're referring
to this game I mean Kay this another
game I haven't heard of what the other
one is oh my god oh I was about to look
I put us in for a second now we're gonna
fade away goodbye we want you guys to
see there we go oh two of them oh your
crystal level 18 that's cool I gotta get
on that grind yeah it's gonna be
hopefully we can reach the the dojo
because I'm thinking that the experience
from those attempts are gonna be a
little higher oh definitely I had to
drop off some Tim Tim at the in my
little Bank because I caught too many I
think you have it you have a cap of six
and I wanted to catch new ones so the
for the first time I had it drops them
off yeah broke my heart
totally coop says I don't think the
violin is a good choice another
instrument would have been better so
people like the violin I think at first
but after a while for me I mean it does
get old but I also like I said I put
these games I go in autopilot mode I
think it's dramatic but it's not like as
heroic as like the pokemon theme like
it's good but no I still like it at this
point so Mike's FS have we shown how to
capture some time in the wild yes we
actually just caught one like maybe five
minutes ago we kinda nice a little like
ferret
which was kind of it's kind of neat yeah
it's gonna let me get out of here thanks
that was just a random person not an NPC
though they are online that one's an NPC
right actually if my crystals fine we
want to maybe head back to heal everyone
well yeah but I just like I don't want
to spend too much time running back and
forth to and as long as crystals okay
then then we're fine yeah we'll just
swap with someone else
oh cool I don't know you can do that
from that screen right there that's cool
I might have to use one of those repels
I forget what they call them in the in
the game just cuz like experience from
wild temp times I know it's not nearly
as oh the sense sense yeah those aren't
cool they just push you off the radar
and they don't make you have so many
wild fights mics if you want to catch
another yeah I can do one right now just
for you bro see how it looks I guess he
just missed it but no big deal yeah dang
one thing I've noticed is I haven't seen
any like critical hits or anything like
that it's just super effective and not
very effective types of like that there
yeah I have a little a fraction system
where it's like half or a quarter or
something right right even then it
doesn't do half the help i stuff to like
actually be coded that means there we go
it's like it you're throwing a little
debit card at it oh that happened to me
yesterday that was very sad because it
was like that again look at that health
like you can't do much more without
knocking it out yeah seriously
give it a go mr. v asks how much it's
gonna cost
David did you have the price I think you
I deliver so I think yesterday we were
saying about 30 but I was looking around
the media and I was getting different
I'll just release it we're gonna
different like answers online side ah
it's actually really hard to say TBD
yeah but I know it's not gonna be like a
full price game or anything like that
okay I don't know the battles are not
all 2v2 especially in the beginning it's
uh you can have one v two or after there
to run out they can throw more in but it
maxes it tops out at 2 V 2 I believe I
think it does and the other thing to to
notice is that the moment that you get
to Tim Thames you only draw to tempo so
I don't see an option where I could
where we send out one okay I would like
to just send out once might get the most
of of the XP I see I see you because
we're trying to do the grind yesterday
one of my temp Thames got knocked out
and I didn't swap in another one and so
my main Tim Tim was fighting against -
oh yeah yeah it didn't work out cuz you
know I was underpowered but it was an
option like I just didn't switch in a
new temp temp that's very interesting
[Music]
these are like World Team Rocket Boys
almost they have their little hats any
cool evolutions we're trying to get
there man we've seen a few like there
are they are out there in the wild we're
trying to evolve our starter Tim Tim and
some of them are cool ones I have seen
are actually very cool
hypnosis yeah go to sleep but I was was
I hate with a happier ability this he's
got caffeinated doesn't ability oh yeah
didn't mind have that yesterday we kept
laughter everyone we're like that's it
ability being caffeinated that's really
funny
there you go does this move pretty
powerful let's see wow this is good
crystal this is good yeah it's the
strongest move I have so far sounds like
a band or something stare down Darien
this game is not out yet it is we have a
very early alpha build and the early
access will begin on Steam on January
21st it is not out to the public just
yet so appreciate you tuning in hope you
like what you Steve there we go
got this out for the count
oh he's got more no they love these
birds yeah they do rock I do they're
pretty common like early game one it
seems but I asked how is this legal it
looks like a direct ripoff well I guess
enough creative creative liberties were
taken it's not you know enough to to get
by definitely inspired by but I don't
know if that hold up in court
you tell me man there are enough
elements as far as like outside of the
actual 10/10 battling and stuff like
there's they introduced the MMO in-game
chat live characters on your screen
right mean it's it's different it up
it's tweaked enough but I mean I won't
get into much more of that as far as
legality because I don't really know
what is the game gonna release as we
have a early access coming up on the
21st after that I don't know if there's
an official date for the rest because
you know what they are they do plan to
have console releases like twitch Xbox
and ps4 but maybe as late as 2021 stare
you're gonna stay all stared you down
[Music]
nice oh no sorry yeah it's over and
we're back we don't want to block the
in-game battle area so I'd put us back
in there you go
nice you have hecka bombs pick up bombs
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah a lot of these are okay then I'll
leave a sunscreen runs away remember
when I try that yesterday it's like
failed to run away when not Zachary says
looks better devs will probably put more
TLC into Tim Tim - there you go I'm
sorry thinking of the future yeah he's
got some faith in this game whoa what
are those no what is that
he seems rekt me actually earlier I was
going up against one a little bit these
levels are low so it's not too bad
my man I was getting worked it was
really unfortunate and then it's scooch
us out of here again so that check and
see your moves there you go oh oh you
did like you flicked it so no they're
bullying you they're picking on crystals
specifically God okay how do I play this
because no matter what whatever all
wasted on this guy even though he's
almost dead but as long as I don't get
two attacks coming
yeah cuz that would just reverse what
you did like healing them exactly is
there a full heal yet not that I have
something there is a tonic plus or a
ball plus which does like alright we're
out here on the grind that was your nose
your last move there bro no actually
what it barn she barn let me say barn Qi
are there legendaries I don't think
we've made it that far to answer that
yeah that is asking I don't know if they
would be legendaries is the early access
is that that's definitely like endgame
stuff right yeah I mean good question
for down the road now you got me
thinking about it mmm we're good we're
good we're actually I don't know I'll
just kill myself again and then
hopefully open my paw
[Music]
all right oh I would like any hurt
himself
oh who are there any mythical again I
don't think so we haven't made it far
enough to confirm I'm sure something
like that will be down the line don't
you think David but oh but we haven't
made it that far there's not a lot of
there's a little bit of story you know
but it's not like you know how we had
Pokemon back in the day and there was
the anime and there was all this lore
with this game it's a fresh start so we
don't know much in the backstory yet I
don't have four bombs I love that it
works so quickly too
so yeah this is something I really liked
better than Pokemon at the moment is the
use of a smoke bomb which is essentially
like an escape rope if you think about
it hold they still have those in Pokemon
where you can escape a cave through the
rope ah that's cool yeah and then it
spawns you right back to the nearest
center there is this game out now ask
chat nope not yet we have an early build
early access for everyone else will be
January 21st on Steam only uh will
McNair goes for the love of God please
stop hitting we're supplying exactly
you're right but the thing is is that
some of these birds actually aren't
flying type even though they look like
birds like it's really confusing and on
the other one heck that I was using is
actually not a flying attack it's a
normal attack dang but well it threw me
off member cuz your Pokemon Pokemon keep
your tempt em looks like a grass type
but now I decide it's a crystal type so
that's the thing like if you're a
Pokemon veteran look I am it's it's
dangerous to fall under those
kind of like autopilot moves it's not
true because you look at this so I'm
gonna use crystal dust write that on
this on Swallow just knock them out but
look at here so when burst is the
flying-type not pet heck is a normal
type a keto by the color yeah oh yeah
that's normal that's a toll which is
like a this is flying so that's kind of
a you see from the symbol that green
symbol that's the flying symbol go cool
the white ones the normal they call it
neutral okay nice you put in work on
these guys that little cocoon guy he's
just done for all they can do is defense
up
[Music]
Maude this game and important' into it
is this on humblebundle um it's I
believe it's published by them it's like
developed by crema and then published by
humble bundles anything yeah I think so
either way both of their names are on
the website there come on crystal level
19 ooh that's cool I think we can do it
we got another hour here we'll get
really close oh boy
maybe maybe not maybe yeah we'll see at
the very least if if chat does want to
see a evolution we can for sure for sure
[Music]
yeah I want that pig one pig a pig
that's what it's called I want that one
where are the pig face
oh no trying to poisoning them Bao asks
so how does it involve just through
leveling no through leveling but you
have to oh your starter ones different
though no no no they're all different so
it's not that they evolve at a certain
level but it's how many levels they
evolve with you with you so like you
level up right so a Pokemon might evolve
at level 16 but attempt 10 will evolve
after leveling up sixteen levels does
that make sense yeah okay I forgot wool
did I say that right you level up as a
character and then like like on your own
with there how do you mean sorry like so
you like your player right you level up
on your own are you just only the
temtempo only this times up yeah you're
okay you're not you know how did I miss
both okay okay
whack will says I think this game looks
fun actually it's only to be two battles
oh yeah yeah so far it is we've only
seen 2 v 2 or 1 v 2 whatever
nice wait was that yours no one that was
the pig you think I like take a pic
uh-huh whatever he's the enemy paradox
hey what's going on
thanks for joining us today playing some
more tempt I'm trying to level up level
20 yeah and you made two hundred and
twenty five buckareenies monies rubies
gold man we're close though are you
close to the eggs I don't know I don't
know how far along you are in the cave
the map though will tell us if you're at
all interested
I think the map only tells you how far
you kind of are right like it doesn't
show you where you can go wow it didn't
when I was outside what is that oh yeah
when you're outside though it's only
shows you where you've been like it
doesn't show you all the other areas
you're right yeah you have to explore
them exactly I see yeah what is Isis
looks like an unfinished house
dojo leader right yeah are the I forget
her relationship with she was like the
dojo leader daughter she's stuck in
there I missed all the child yeah see
that's the that's the only issue I have
after finally a new body the only issue
I have with this game is that like none
none of the actual quests and storylines
or anything compel me yet
sure I just they all seem kind of
throwaway e they're all Sammy but
apparently we're looking for someone
named Laurie Lottie so we're just gonna
we'll be on the lookout I'm just gonna
you know battle these bright interests
[Music]
that's the starter cool that's the melee
starter which I think I think my crystal
versions like stupid strong against them
nice skipping this game is not out on
the Nintendo switch it's planned for it
right now it severely
it's a wearing at alpha build it's very
early if you have steam you'll be able
to play oh you'll be able to play this
on steam on the 21st via early access
but as far as consoles it'll we're
looking for dates right now it's TVA
PlayStation 4 switch an Xbox though were
announced whoops forgot to there we go
[Music]
okay but if I were to attack with oh
yeah spacey strategy master Chad is
asking so is this any good though
rotations brownie yeah it's good oh you
have better vision than me David I'm
trying to squint and read that little
Maine's Pradesh is brownie yeah I think
I think it's fun this guy looks bummed
out
[Music]
this caveman caves a brutal dude they
are year there were leveling up though
that's what we're here to do we want to
we want to evolve our crystal here oh
yeah need that like a new purchase oh oh
[Music]
she's a spook visitor I got this oh yeah
I do like a sigh Pat that's his name I
like his look is like helmet Michele
helmet things I thought it was an
evolution of that blue oh no it's not
there's some see via our thumbnail our
thumbnail today's thumbnail is the
evolution they show both of them this I
wanted though I need some more history
on this guy psycho Qaeda yeah except
like I don't know that's so confused it
doesn't look like he's a migraine either
work yeah poor dude Oh
[Music]
defense down over for you
[Music]
even quacked Oh No
well that's good she only had one it was
kind of high level though - it was like
19 something paradox is listening the
the type advantages for the starters
semental is stronger than melee which is
stronger than crystal which is stronger
than mental right it's like that
rock-paper-scissors thing I like how
it's called mental it's like don't f
with me man's mental nothing in like
mental powers or anything no either
it's absolutely mental nice okay let's
go
I don't think I've seen these yet who
come okay they're like little water eel
dragon thing so I really like the design
of those me too yeah God stop picking on
crystal young Holly in the chat says
this looks better than Pokemon that's
irritating Jackson in the chat is asking
should I get this or Pokemon shield
well Pokemon shield is out now David's
going with the Pokemon shield it's a you
know yeah it's here it's now but if this
was fully open I think you have a
stronger debate right yeah that one's
gonna be up to you my friend this one
won't be out for a while January 21st
for early access on PC only right so
that's another thing to consider but if
you like how this looks maybe wait it
out maybe get both you know you have
time in between both to get save up some
money get both did you guys start over
or something you have a different temp
10 oh you were here yesterday
what's appreciate you coming back yeah
we're playing David's account he does
have a hit a different starter Tim Tim
yeah and we're trying to level our goal
today is to try to level him up and
evolve him to the next
and that takes some grinding but we are
here and thank you for returning this is
a crystal oh yeah open up the house
screaming there I love that move
I mean I love that move it saved my ass
like 20 times yesterday Oh Fozzie what
what is this oh sorry I yelled riding
the big confused I've never seen this
this September I love his teeth he's
like look like a punk
he's like the body of like a bear I
don't even know like weird longer arms
funny head he's got me Lightning though
lightning
crystal this double damage is lightning
wonderful oh that's a cool move I like
the animation man
oh no that's why I got worked note oh is
this more Pokemon or Digimon inspired
both David says both I mean we're in
mid-battle right now folks something oh
[Music]
there you go you got your technique
there how long does it take to evolve
these well regular Tim Tim they they
level up pretty quickly and evolve
quickly your starter ones though this
one right here that we're looking
on-screen takes a little longer your
starter temp them need to level up to
roughly level 30 if it varies but that's
what we're trying to do today we're
trying to grind it out picking all these
fights with people picking all these
fights man and if we get to it we're
trying to get to a dojo to it get some
more extra experience
absolutely yeah trying to get all these
items as well because there's been some
pretty good once awakened areas bomb
pluses like those I missed it what is a
wait gonna do it like if someone's
asleep from a spell okay sick
so in Pokemon they call them awakenings
okay
tried and true our friends here these
two a pyrex about 800 you're right I
don't remember any of the types here
with and I never remember what it is if
it's like a flying or if it's like a new
year yet nature it's not gonna attack us
I haven't noticed you are there tempt em
with two types you know kind of like
Pokemon that's a good question I've been
support okay well that might simplify
things you know yeah for sure for sure
that's how it used to be in the olden
days I mean I'm grandpa Richie over here
like I remember one Pokemon are one type
that's it but they changed that for the
better because you know you're not
changing stalin's grandpa Richie that's
me
I remember pokemon red and yeah if you
ever see us on stream again like yeah
chat only referred to me as grandpa
Richie now yeah I'm aged cheese you got
this chats got a good memory too man
oh yeah few times when I came on to like
play a couple of like sports games in
August or something like madder than
that yeah when I came on for I think I
might have been 2 K or FIFA like 3
people was like oh David's gonna be AI
was like destiny
we got sports yeah little Pokemon happy
happy very happy you guys are
typecasting
ah yes the dojo is temp temp speak for a
gym yeah yes chat was asking absolutely
you got this is a pretty hefty battle oh
it's official release in the 21st no
it's it's well it's early access begins
on 21st of this month so you will be
able to play me we got an early code
hip-hip-hooray but if you want to jump
on yourself 21st on Steam only you know
I keep saying there are plans for
console releases it's announced it just
it's a matter of when they haven't
announced a date for gifts for switch
and Xbox one
Tim Tim Tanner equals gym leader that's
what they call our dojo master right
yeah yeah their lingo you got this you
got this David Young and Dave I wonder
how close I saw the stairs I think you
are nearing the exit of the gym
hopefully you find out there's two
passing okay but I think you just like
convince someone it just takes you there
it would suck we reached a dead end nice
another level up you guys salty they
lost and we're back oh my god I think
this is a dead end
no wait oh my god with them all the map
help over there well if that's where you
came in there we go okay buy some more
good applies yeah you need some money
and then we'll take the other path I
like this song of course it got quiet as
soon as I it's like now it's like it
started off nice
there you go
[Music]
back in the cave y'all win word for it
[Music]
dang it
I'm gonna run away oh yeah like these
guys are only giving me like abs let's
save our battles huh well if you can run
away sometimes it doesn't work okay good
[Music]
make it worth it
hey there was an online player this is
the way that I went you think now the
map might help because you've explored a
little bit em oh oh to get into that
part you have to enter through another
room and it's a dead end
what's up flim-flam I think yeah you're
way out up into the left oh here that
was so fast come on don't blame me dude
okay I do love those sense though they
make for live-streaming pretty great
what did that guy say it's probably
nothing but the stones don't like this
games just throwing some
rocks on our path we're gonna go back to
that shop I'm gonna sell the two things
that I just got okay make some money buy
some sin by some sense yeah he knows
chad is asking what is this on we are
playing on PC we have an early codes and
if you have steam you'll be able to play
this yourself on Steam early access on
January 21st
oh hey DT welcome I can only buy one
more set what do we got it
sell your temp timeless kidding yourself
all the awakener I don't care for if
they go to sleep they wake up pretty
quickly I noticed like after a turn or
two tops and then bombs I have two
tonics five ether plus three we need
that we need this end yeah we need the
sense for the sake of progression
give me all the cents DT is asking what
does this game about well dude you beat
me I haven't been paying attention the
quest nights it's been leveling up yeah
I guess it's like if we were to take a
wild guess I would assume it's your you
know and an aspiring tamer tim-tim
tainer yeah and you're just trying to be
the best tamer in all the land
okay yeah but if if you've never heard
of this game it's it's a Pokemon style
MMO game so they do how do players
interact I haven't really pulled that
off yet have you David like I think
there's a button I think if you press
like tab or something on the keyboard
you can't interact with a local player
who's standing next to you and there's
also a chat on the bottom left watch
this I'll unblock us for a sec oh there
it is so there's a running chat right
there's a running chat and you keep I
think they might have to be strong
enough for it to like it like reduces
the encounter but it doesn't guarantee
Oh Simon give me the option all right
well you know what
Oh No you run away okay cool whew great
two revives
I'll take sweet Christian says I've
heard of this
I need wait I read an article saying is
tempt him gonna lose Pokemon fans hmm
what the article saying
[Music]
yeah okay well this is this other
section yeah that is just a circle but I
don't know what happens if you go up
there so maze like yeah but I'm not
talking to make sure none of them are
leaving body oh right because that's a
side quest right yeah we are playing on
or not a side bus I think that's quite
sad to get oh oh right cuz she was
involved with the dojo that lady alright
good here in your room good stuff I'm on
the right path I'm gonna clear us out so
you guys can check out the battle on the
bottom left you got this David Young and
David
yogi Dame yeah we were just saying that
the the scent didn't last very long at
home no and in fact it did even well
it's sort of work like David said it's a
it's not guaranteed but it'll drop the
amount of encounters you find in the
wild
well yeah overall it didn't last very
long it should be like double that time
paying good money for those oh yeah
although that was a horrible sound
yeah it sounded like a dolphin - I did
not like that
- real bro that haircut the fish looks
awesome
[Music]
Mick dub make that was mcdhh up saying
the fish looks awesome it doesn't look
fine it has a really cool like tail
whack attack what was it called a fin
slap
[Music]
pokemon fan in the chat says this is a
bootleg of coke well coming from a
Pokemon fan you know that's a hard
that's it that's an opinion right there
that's a tape yeah we talked about this
quite a few times like it's sure you
know but it's not a bad thing and there
are more things here that vary it from
Pokemon maybe not dramatically but
enough to give it a shot I'd say right
we're having fun here chad is asking why
don't you focus on taking out one at a
time you know I don't play that way
either David I try to split it up to
lower both of them what it what's your
take it's a good take it really isn't
and I do that most of the time but it
also kind of depends on the temp temp
you're going up against right mm-hmm so
like if I have the reason why it's kind
of difficult to spend two attacks on one
temps em sometimes is because your
stamina it's every move you make matters
and if I let's say I do an attack that
takes out 80% you can it's awesome
Tim Tim it's like whoa no no no I'm so
if temps m1 spends you know a move that
does 80% of the damage mhm attempt m2
does another move and it's a lot of
salmon as well just to take out the
remaining 20% it's not as effective
right I'd rather use that on another
full health attempting to get the most
out of it yeah yes you mean you don't
need to finish off this much health with
like a full-blown attack yeah so and
then yeah exactly
that's pretty much the gist of it but no
you're absolutely right and like
sometimes especially with wild temps
then where if I really want to kind of
get things done all
I'll definitely use two moves on the
same yeah it's a good approach that's
usually how sometimes to beat our I saw
that guy dial USA he is the guy Lopez on
yesterday too what are you playing this
game on we have it on PC currently we
have a no it's not free I see chat
chiming in here it's not free early
access will be available on the 21st on
Steam only and we don't we can't confirm
the price yet the the generally people
are saying I think of $29.99 dollar game
you know thirty dollar game can't
confirm but it will eventually be ported
to everything there are plans to put it
on ps4 Xbox switch no mobile plans so
one thing um I don't you guys just
noticed I did two attacks on the same
but there was an ability called shared
pain where no matter what it went to the
other attempt em so that was but I have
a move that Richard are we using
yesterday to call it the shrill voice
that one which would attack you at the
same time so my first attack just now
didn't damage and defeat that other
opponent it would have
at the same time but it sucks you can
only use your voice every other move
it's like weird oh yeah and it takes a
lot of it's a high damage move though
I've had a lot of success with that move
accidently good put us on screen for a
second in DT says $30.00 is really
expensive in my country I hope I hope
we'll see that's just a kind of a
rumored price hopefully it'll be lower
that'd be cool oh I pronounced a micron
mic dub like microphone
these guys are trying to move the
concept forward so props to them ah the
whole Pokemon concept yeah they're doing
it they're doing it you know yeah
switching up a little bit keeping it
really familiar though I was uh I was
talking to Jake GameSpot's very own
Jacob Dekker the Baker he's been running
our weekly podcast which you guys
continue into every Wednesday it's
really really good and I was asking him
his opinion on it was like hey you know
you've been playing time cent for a
couple hours and I'm like what do you
think and you pretty much reach that
sentiment where it's like I like some of
the things that it's doing some of the
other stuff maybe not so much sure but
it's it's still uh it's still it's still
look steps board you know what I mean if
you're trying to push the genre for to
someone mentioned earlier which is cool
yeah MTO gaming says I love the solo
violin violin quite a bit a lot of
people like it a lot of people don't but
it does seem to be the battle musics
yeah Squidward is not down got David -
laughs you didn't see and have the
camera he was laughing yeah everyone
here is an idiot except me
yeah I love that piece so these guys
seem to be like the Team Rocket of yeah
did they have a name and they have
little matching hats and everything yeah
there definitely is a rim overconfident
look I know that I do not expect
I love that there's a dozen things I
could have expected
oh no oh okay
and this say let's see it's all those
again oh but he's weak so it's okay
level 10 yeah so I love that stance the
normal tech move didn't do anything
again
little applying feathering garlic
doesn't do anything either
oh geez oh we're kind of screwed so I
might as well just not use as much
stamina there you go
DT thanks for joining us he's he's taken
off for the day appreciate it Oh days
see ya 54 bucks you got ripped off now
it was only one attempt M oh look at
this whole group of them I'm just gonna
leave us off for a little bit I keep
switching on and off David you're in the
middle of a thousand battles here I know
I'm just trying to be good
[Music]
quit skill says I will happily pay $30
for this an MMO inspired by Pokemon yes
he says hell yeah no I mean yes but no I
love the little piggy character oh good
okay they each have like one oh my god
there's like or in a row you got this
dude and then I'll get different
personalities once like overconfident
one reckless you guys can call me that's
another evolution that's the evolution
of a cocoon the spore guy yeah oh cool
let me here let me let me take him take
him out so you guys can see what his
little baby version looks like
Oh Mike dub in the chat says I'm
definitely buying US after Wow classic
okay for sure for sure ooh
well that's gonna do anything why did it
do it like lick yeah did you [ __ ]
sharply sure that is dude I love their
names these these the squad yeah
reckless we can call me elderly Richie
I'm gonna beat you all on my own I do
like that um when you're out in the wild
after the battles you can see your
party's health yeah once we get out of
this battle which is nice because you
don't have to open up like your menu all
the time to like check up on people
what's up you just see at a glance yeah
that's nice
then then thing you got knocked up Wow
very good dude this thing's foolish
foolish what missed it foolish I think
their suffix is all the same bill sotto
sotto undeceived all Soto
honey how many adjectives can come up
with this whoa what is oh is that the
evolved form of that one little hair box
thing fair thing yeah
Oh he sits on his tail cool pose he
looks comfy you got this
he's got exceptional balance he does Oh
shove standing your I know have no
attacks of missed Oh
one time I've had an attack miss on me
once oh really
yeah it discs it does come up it says
like but it failed yes free beans I like
that I like that how they laid them out
there were a bunch of bad guys to fight
but they each had one Tim time
appreciated
who that your whole squad is doing good
spots John
dude there's gotta be that lady lot oh
that must be her over there I miss it on
the top right after this guy oh I can
catch him I don't have him yet sweet
[Music]
[Music]
unity asks how many creatures do you
have how many how many temp them David
you got at least six of them I've I've
got at least six but nice but the game
has quite a bit I think the game has
it's well supposed to go up to like 161
total whoo uh this is just off the vici
also wow I do not expect it you were
trying to catch it
oh yeah no biggie no biggie
[Music]
I keep wanting to say but I forget that
it just oh here we got lady there she is
someone's looking for you that can only
be wind ward for it isn't that backwards
[Laughter]
whatever little do you remember what was
effective against the oh crap your
crystal dust want to thank your still
does yeah thanks crystal store works
again skanky so I might as well take
this guy out first MVP right here is the
easier crystal best movie yeah how do
you see any starters in the wild
yes okay I don't know alright I have not
seen any in the wild I've gone against a
lot of trainer or tamers in the wild but
it's also confirmed in the wiki that you
can like they're not meant to be
exclusive
I see I see oh crap I knew I missed that
up I've never heard my name pronounced
like that what'd you say I said I have
to zoom in here oh is it unit on oh you
know what I'm not even up I want to
Connecticut solids a unit an yeah my bad
so it's a beautiful it's name that I'm
just not used to I was just pressing a
and like looking off to chat ever you
know what happened Savior someone was
saying that the developers want to bring
crossplane to this game so that would be
pretty big as well says quits bill
[Music]
turn-based thing it's not like you're
you know shooting things or that you
need like moments a moment
yeah frame accurate right Bob Jones in
this chat what's going on man good to
have you here uh yes Larry it is
currently only on PC we have an early
alpha build of the game and if you are
interested it'll be in early access on
Steam January 21st you know what every
wise there's no violence what happened I
don't know but I thought the music was
getting a little Sammy and I just
realized I'm like bobbing my head you
are yeah but I was like why people
violins gone bro I do like this one this
track
[Music]
oh cool have the chat over here too I
can see clear ah I have the chat on this
other screen it's like I'm focusing on
the screen that's kind of far away I
just like to read yeah I'm trying to
read the chat on this little monitor
that's got understand we're not we're
not normally our very own purchase
currently at sea yes right now hell yeah
you know doing uh doing some really good
work there mic dub says if they make
this cross play it'll explode IMO I
think so it's never a bad thing to
implement it's harder I'm sure for any
program or whatever but since they do
plan to release this for the ps4 Xbox
and switch and PC cross play would be
clutch yeah it wouldn't like bring more
people on board I think oh I can totally
see her name now Yonatan he said you
guys are great thanks appreciate it
tried not to butcher your name and
you're still praising as we love you
yeah
we're serving you're sweating it out
oh this is so great let's chat here on
the right yeah and every day whoop them
they're like not even the surfing lady
was this tough which means that we're
better hey have you ran into Mia that's
pretty yeah what the I think I got
called the club by Max and the beginning
of the game you know your rival max with
the green hair oh great well I'm gonna
scoop this away again you guys got to
see this oh no you know healing oh
you're okay I got I got it all psyched
up for nothing SS Rojo ass will it come
out on switch day one well there there's
more than one day one I believe because
whoa what is that didn't do much
Oh grout look dope no no it's fine I'm
just at this point I'm repeating myself
because it's it's you know this will be
available on Steam only at first for
early access on the 21st there are plans
to release it on the switch ps4 and Xbox
but no dates have been announced for
that year but it's in the works
so no won't be released on switch day
one yeah I don't like that but it seems
oh and knocks it yourself out though
sick am i only good oh whoa a lot of XP
damn you know after this if I go to a
training spot I just need to get rid of
all of my concepts and just keep my
started just crystal and like buy so
many bombs to heal
yes on a Susie Romano likes to sit now
does it work yeah there is and they're
calling it stamina actually but yeah
it's like it even has like the blue bar
that most games that use mana kind of
utilize essentially every move that you
have has a certain number of mana that
it'll use up or stamina mm-hmm so and
like you'll notice I have five sitting
the left if I use any of these moves
it'll take away from my health and it'll
also prevent me from attacking for one
turn so I think how to tell you how much
your health you're gonna lose though
yeah see how it's blinking us but what I
can do I can still use this move and I'm
gonna use it on low Ally but I can use a
tonic or an ether on the other present
for the other time time that would have
been these my takeaway kaku's move use
it on crystal but I still attack with
Christmas because the items can be
applied first that's right yeah you know
anyway share something instead of well
instead of attacking yeah it's kind of
yeah you can use your other Pokemon
Stern shadow ninja in the chat asks is
this game free to play uh no no no no
it'll be an early access but I don't
think it'll be free and that's on the
21st on Steam only simply asks oh no he
says this game looks good oh yeah
Oh Mike dub asks are you guys gonna
stream any more of this throughout the
week I'd love to see the progression
mm-hmm we appreciate that feedback that
kind of helped us stream it again today
if you guys do like what you're seeing
maybe we can go for the rest of week but
I'm not sure we got it we got to do some
you know some research talk about a
little bit yeah yeah why not the one
thing I think it is worth saying though
that the output ends tomorrow
I win in a way I'll double-check it's
tomorrow maybe as far as the ninth I
think from the sixth to the ninth okay
which nice I'm here on Friday
yes very cool very cool Tim Tim Michael
asks what is this game my friend
this is Tim Tams if you like Pokemon
you're in the right place this is an MMO
inspired game our MMO game yeah it's
fired by Pokemon so I was tryna say
someone in chat was asking is this the
dojo leak or is this is this where it's
happening I don't think so because I
would like an arena but but this is
clearly some kind of boss I
we've just been battling a lot of
minions and they remind me a lot of do
you think that's like that's I thought
that's kind of why I like chat ask that
because it kind of felt like you were
fighting the little people before the
boss the format is similar but hmm we'll
see David says no I say maybe yeah let's
wager fortunately I can't I have to rest
so I gotta rest rest skip a turn and
then maybe
[Music]
Scott no scoffs good will it have player
trading I believe so I mean I'm not sure
yeah you know what I'm not gonna confirm
that because I haven't seen much about
that actually that's weird
[Music]
Mike dub says this lady you're battling
was in the trailer
I think she's fairly significant Oh
Jonathan said I don't know are you just
playing the same section of the game
that you played the other day so yes and
no we passed that section and we're also
on a different account yes we are we're
on David's account yes he has the new
starter or the other one right there's a
green one crystal this is the the grind
to evolve is tougher than I thought it's
extremely tough we're yeah you might end
up having to evolve a different temp
temp but you guys yeah see what
evolutions look like absolutely smart
what happened
look Kyle's here oh and I got the Ford
when we're ki whoa like a revive know
what to do more cents 10 cents
down with that yeah I'll use another cuz
I got ten yeah and they were free like a
guy'll he's here the homie guy with his
little mental yeah so I think we
probably have to go back to that prison
the jail cell yeah where what's her name
was that one dojo lady and let her know
like okay we rekt rekt what's her face
for you yeah quizzical asks you have a
favorite starter as of right now crystal
this is dope crystal put yeah yeah yeah
I'm gonna agree I'd even pick crystal
yesterday and I think crystal that move
that one right there crystal does is
like worth picking crystal alone quick
it knocked out this little mmm piece of
cake
I am I really like three starters was
crystal some sort of like snazzy I think
yeah I think that's right the little
monkey
and then the like the male a monkey and
then the mental one which I forgot the
name but we named it Alex
yeah yeah I still don't remember its
original name yeah that was a pretty
cool one too I think
but I liked crystal because it reminded
me just more of like a Pokemon it
doesn't it looks yeah it does look like
a Pokemon like a crystal a grat even
though we discussed this earlier it's
not a grass-type or latest what are the
codes of nature fighter types that the
nature is the game's grass type yeah
we're more this is more of the
like I don't want to compare it to steel
but it's like something hmm hey yeah
you're free
[Music]
yeah I miss all the lessons meet the
weirdo then Wow okay I have to hurry
back to erisa lab why don't you come see
me in the dojo sick all right so we're
gonna go to the city to the dojo and
good stuff making some progress and
leveling up hurt wolf says I saw some
guy posting on their forums about a
player trading bug so perhaps it is in
the game you know I wouldn't I wouldn't
doubt it what's tenth you know what's a
ten-time if you can't trade yeah I know
it'd be an interesting thing to leave
out is all I'm saying
for sure there you go tell me give me my
money Bob Jones ass metal iron are there
that's what we were talking about right
like they have a metal type was it
though I think so we have to look this
up there is the Wikipedia on this game
is growing and they do have all the
types so it might be something worth
looking up yes in fact I'm I can purge
it does this all the time I can do that
oh no I closed the streams giving
yesterday and it was pretty bad no I was
my bad I gave you the green light yes
press that button shut down but it was
just funny cause like the phrasing I was
like okay I'm just gonna X out of this
and then it just went out it black
that's out the problem was that I could
still see chat oh man they were probably
like what the well we're in good we're
in good hands hello chat gets it he
laughs we moved everything oh here you
go I'll take us out on the battle here
saw like it's while I tell you guys
about the all the types do you want to
read them off - are you're in battle
okay so the Tim Tim types here are all
of them neutral fire nature water
electric
Digital crystal wind earth mental my
favorite melee and toxic what
so in Pokemon terms that is normal fire
grass water electric psychic ground
slash rock maybe death lying crystal I
still don't know mmm digital I still oh
now ooh and then melee which is fighting
a toxic which is poison cool uh okay so
I'm interested in crystal then the ones
we don't know the wild cards I talked to
that tour group and pretended I was a
tour guide leader and they were like oh
great job thank you
[Music]
is this a PC game yeah we are playing on
PC it's a announced for PC it'll be out
for PC the early access for the PC
version is the 21st it will be released
to all the other consoles also later on
though Bob Jones crashing the stream no
no I did not I faked it
[Music]
maybe the net it probably be a big
building what in it oh look to the right
what's that
[Music]
because I do remember going I got told
to go away that guy told me to go away a
van well we're you gotta get out of my
way dude okay this yep Oh God you did
not mind the gap David dude oh okay whoa
I like this all yours the fight oh ma
is there a way even to jump how could
you have what ability was reckless of me
no I don't know I would have done the
same thing ty says I imagine crystal is
like the rock type hmm we just run right
through it
good luck David you've got this well
that's okay we need a we need a battle
trainers all right yes we do we have 15
minutes bro yeah cam says we need more
pokemon clone games I'm all here for
this I'm all for this yes how many 10
Tempe hold on yourself with yourself six
I believe is the yeah six yeah quit
skill says Oh some original Pokemon gym
vibes right here I like it all right now
I got a little bit of that too walking
in like you know a dojo is a gym got
this freaking violence back it is back
yeah
oh yeah I'm not you know what there is
an earth-type so I don't know if crystal
would be a rock-type I wonder though
we're gonna have to find out in the
future
[Music]
two eyes gonna go very concerned itself
but gotta do for the greater good man is
that when David says no we need more
Digimon clone games Oh poison both of
you
rude
[Music]
that's plush the tonic plus HP and what
Oh stamina stamina yeah if I get them
out
oh it's over for you Oh Eileen peace out
ah
[Music]
so I can just knock bah Rico fariko says
the music feels like Professor Layton
decided to battle Pokemon that's good
it's that violin right crystal is a
crystal type oh you'll have to excuse me
I'm a little behind on my pokemon lingo
hmm so if that's true yeah that makes
absolute sense Oh another is their
Christmas oh then you are a liar well I
think you're just kidding you might be
talking about the game itself like in
the game like that's the oh we know the
the the spelling so crystal with the e
that's what that's my starter Oh crystal
is it yeah I just read that wrong cuz
I'm a doofus ya know but yeah so you're
absolutely right that's my starter is a
crystal type okay yeah ignore the last
minute there because I misspoke nice I
can okay so here's what we're gonna do
I'm still gonna make my way back to the
gym but we're gonna look for Haro oh so
we can involve them so we can catch and
evolve it because it seems like crystal
needs a bit more work before you can get
to that really high enough level
but we do want to show you guys at least
one cents on the ball because you can
kinda see that animation yeah we haven't
involved with the attempt em yet have we
have oh this is perfect
of course you're looking for a fight and
nothing's happening my god you he's
gonna barf watch here oh you talk to
your Tim Tims
Jesus really game nose dude yeah the
game's like oh you trying to get
something done it smells fear yeah there
we go that evolves into something cool
but it does it does I think okay evolve
your to Y or is that one of them that
like takes a lot of it was a digital
professor when he gives it to you why he
was a gift I realized it he says it like
only will do something if you go to like
to a certain area or like reacts a
certain way
mmm so but but you're right Kaku can
evolve so we're gonna chat assay near
your Kaku evolution is pretty close
pretty glow sorry sick yeah well good
okay knock you up there no your crystals
poison crystal can take it tough it out
Chris I'm an abusive tamer timezones and
the irony thisit's like tame yeah
Oh two of them in the wild Ataru
I concur you got this got it I love that
sound
check it out
oh no you just yep oh oh no not heavy no
good cut it out
she use oh no that's a nature type
well Raphael says to why is not digital
really I say digital that was already
know maybe maybe he's maybe he's right I
think what's digital is the your rival
started right max because he's like I
got a digital Pokemon it looks like only
number two and yeah okay you're right
you're right
oh we're only finding one digital type
right now and it's oh really
well let me go back I can I can scope
out is Kaku get a ball oh oh that's cool
and we're
and let's see my top I'm looking up on
the official wiki all the tight
[Music]
been a mini Oh looks like evolving
Glaceon by touching glaciers or madness
um but being in a magnetic field
yeah for Hawaii I didn't have to agree
with that
touching glaciers oh man I didn't buy a
surfboard have you David you didn't buy
a surfboard in this game yeah so I try
to talk to the one guy with the
surfboard he was like is all out yeah oh
yeah that's right happen to me too that
happened to us on stream yesterday or
was it just the quenches oh okay main
page
[Music]
this doesn't kill the Pajaro I might try
to catch it
oh it's gonna wreck it Oh No rip haha
that's the one you were looking forward
to damn it did you make this oh you
jumped the ledge man I put us you know
what I'm just gonna leave us off screen
for a little bit here you've got this I
wonder if it's gonna let me damage it
first and then maybe try to catch it
I just why not if it doesn't capture its
legs then it doesn't all we know I
misspoke yesterday the card went all
around until his little feet were
exposed and then it was like nope
all right I thought so
I've got to buy this OST man we have
some fans of the soundtrack already yeah
it's good it's good looks like a little
save disk working like a floppy disk
[Music]
how much is the game we don't have a
final answer we've heard rumors of 30
bucks but we don't know when it comes
out in early access on the 21st right
you will know or we'll keep you updated
if we play this game tomorrow or
something you know D Bell says this s
look swag man
d Bell not a fan of Pokemon or do you
love Pokemon and show this or do you
love Pokemon and you're offended at this
let me know with a I think I do have to
just like jump down that's the whole I
think so too because what other way you
know you can't jump choose your path
wisely
[Music]
this guy has those one evolution it
looks like he's got those uh Brock eyes
that are like squint like like they look
shut yeah why don't you I'm doomed
oh no no no mats i Pat people who roll
with size that only roll with style that
was your first mistake
all right I'm gonna clear us out again
so you can see the battle going on while
you clear us out do you mind going on
the Wii key and clicking on the sentence
yes
yeah oh and look up Kaku and see if it
says nothing it'll evolve whoo okay so I
can kind of get like a good idea what
I'm looking at I got you hmm
oh he just himself what is this sigh Pat
doing Oh - why there's the twine well
you're looking for Kaku what the heck
did I skip let me start from the top
okay
[Music]
still nothing oh yes dude say Kaku both
great Haku that was a cool screen there
let's turn you tight I okay I'm not
gonna lie I got like a little like you
know jolt of excitement down my spine
when I saw that you did and that's like
the same kind of like the same feeling
you get like if you remember that your
first like look one that you evolved oh
yeah you know what I mean yeah like oh
my god like it's gonna happen so yes you
got those vibes dude yeah that's pretty
cool
oh that's cool yeah that actually is
perfect because now look at that cuz we
were able to live a few minutes yeah we
got a few minutes but we also were able
to show you guys how times of all right
which is nice
yeah so short and sweet yeah very but
exciting it's actually interesting
because this Pokemon sword and shield
their evolutions are very short bounce
here oh that's cool yeah they've kind of
like got rid of the they don't draw it
out so much yeah after like 20 years I
get it can you rematch other tamers ones
you have already won no no after you
walk by them they don't even talk to you
yeah you just
Yonatan says a lot of these designs
don't really work for me but I'm a big
fan of crystal there we go
that's David starter crystal scoot yeah
I mean same feeling I was I was really
down with so that's why with nice mic
dub says that evolution animation screen
is sick
oh that's an evolution desolate well
what is that what what no you're going
down whatever you are dude Mike them
seriously how is no one else in chat
hyped about that I was looking at this
screen I caught like half of it was dope
but you got plenty left
this may be our final battle today on
stream yeah it might be
paradoxes bodies the word evolved
instead of where this starts with the TV
oh you mean like mo well yeah I'm trying
to figure out if it later is another way
if like there's another phrase for
evolving or if they were thinking like
cheekily like oh 10 some would have
called it like tea balls yeah made
upwards devolution yeah boy you know
they don't but I would accept it if they
did that's funny I'm not gonna say his
name cuz that's because I might laugh
saying it but he just says hit it with a
brick
see what happens employ anything I might
have did I was injured my foot now got a
sock ooze put it on work man
freshly evolved you got it heck yeah
yeah see that evolved at level 14 so
much quicker than the starter that's
unfortunate but they make you in it for
a while okay you'll you'll so appreciate
it though when once your crystal does
evolve it's gonna be so sick yeah if we
if we come back tomorrow that could be
yeah why don't we just uh I mean you
have one more fighting you yeah yeah I
want to see how close you are to the
final one yeah do the dojo master okay
for the stream oh it's empty
Britt tom is a regular ass guy we're
here to brawl not Babel okay bro damn
see no accurate Wow okay here we go
these these wisecracking guys here
although those sunglasses are pretty
cool how much and what platform chat is
asking let's see well we don't know how
much we haven't confirmed rumors are
$29.99 not come from not confirmed and
it will be on every platform but it'll
start on early access on January 21st
Nader gates for ps4 Xbox one they
haven't been announced yet but its plan
to go everywhere switch everywhere you
know not mobile though
we have a we have an early access build
at the depths in us I believe this game
we're playing in your opinion yeah I
think I think it's getting better dude
like yesterday was a nice humble start
those fun very familiar and now I think
it's getting better
there's a lot of secret right yeah yeah
and now we're seeing more Tim Tim along
the way it's fun that I think I think
that's to your point that's the big
thing right it's like there's more
[Music]
where's the review for this no no no
review yeah it's way too early
yeah we'd only review like actual
releases yes so literally well this is
an alpha stress test but will still
cover it you know you'll find gameplay
on our gameplay GameSpot gameplay
channel for sure that's right we have
the 20 minutes of it already yeah and I
think there's a Pajaro involved evolving
in that gameplay clip too so now I see
that you can definitely check it out yes
really cool we have a video up on
GameSpot gameplay it's our other channel
and it's a it's like the beginning of
the game it's like just after you
customize your character I believe is
when we start it's the beginning of the
game and then it fades out a little bit
to cut out some of the fluff and it goes
further on to where is evolution happens
so you can definitely find it there and
well you know we've definitely streamed
yesterday today maybe tomorrow we'll
talk about it yeah for sure it's not off
the table because it seems like you guys
are you know enjoying the right to
appreciate having yeah that was the
reason why we streamed it again today
positive chat and reviews and comments
yesterday we're just do it again
[Music]
wake up game freak yeah
ooh unit n loves the violin he confirmed
that violin rocks got another violin
lover yep oh yeah antonio it'll be a
while before the full game is out early
access for pcs the 21st but if you're
looking to play it on console even
further maybe even 2021 they're saying
right now we're in the early stages like
David said it's the stress test alpha
build Ren we're not sure yet we may or
may not stream this tomorrow but you
know let me say we're gonna but we will
be streaming like oh yeah we're
streaming tomorrow absolutely yeah
Monday through Friday would stream
whether or not it's this game TBD
[Music]
that's going good dude man I wish I
wanted to get to the dojo master I think
we're close but we went through a lot of
battles he did yeah this was a very uh
how am I trying to say this like this
stream was not like wasted
oh he's he put in a lot of work dude we
put in a lot of work we've defeated Lady
Lottie that's right you rescued the dojo
master we freakin we got into the dojo
you have got Kaku into a socket like yep
the one thing we try to do though is
evolve our starter dang it well I mean
that's that's why we've still got
evolutions out people were able to see
what evolutions look like yeah I ain't
mad
[Music]
Frank the rook says Pokemon company has
no right to be mad when you literally
wait we've literally been telling them
what this is what we wanted for five to
ten years for the last five to ten years
I think that's you know I won't say
that's unfair because I'm sure there's a
definitely a strong group that does that
was asking for things like that
but also I think they kind of do game
freak's been having its own formula that
they've just been working on they have
their own system obviously it's got its
own fan base to write so I think there's
room for everyone
yeah yeah the free bus is very
productive stream we agree thank you so
much and I think that's gonna be
wrapping it up for us though yeah that
was a word I was looking for productive
I was a very productive stream yeah on
that note let's turn this down just a
little to say our goodbyes David thank
you for joining me today and thank you
chat for tuning in we'll be back
tomorrow 11:00 a.m. Pacific Standard
Time
for maybe this maybe not but either way
we will be streaming and we'll see you
then thanks for tuning in you guys bye